python is the most widely used
programming language today
when it comes to solving data science
tasks and challenges
python never ceases to surprise its
audience most
data scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of python
every day hi i'm a bakeshop from simply
learn and well after some thought and a
bit more research
i was finally able to narrow down my
choice of
top python libraries for data science
what are they let's find out
so let's talk about this amazing library
tensorflow which is also one of my
favorites
so tensorflow is a library for high
performance numerical computations with
around 35
000 github comments and a vibrant
community of around 1500 contributors
and it's used across
various scientific domains it's
basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves tensors
and tensors we can say are partially
defined computational objects again
where they will eventually produce a
value that was about tensorflow
let's talk about the features of
tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly used
in deep learning models
and neural networks where we have other
libraries like torch and thiano also
but tensorflow has hands down better
computational
graphical visualizations when compared
to them also tensorflow reduces the
error
largely by 50 to 60 percent in neural
machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where it
can train multiple neural networks
and multiple gpus for highly efficient
and scalable models
this parallel computing feature of
tensorflow is also called pipelining
also tensorflow has the advantage of
seamless performance
as it's backed by google it has quicker
updates frequent new releases with the
latest of features
now let's look at some applications
tensorflow is extensively used in speech
and image recognition
text based applications time series
analysis and forecasting
and various other applications involving
video detection
so favorite thing about tensorflow that
it's already popular among the machine
learning community
and most are open to trying it and some
of us are already using it
now let's look at an example of a
tensorflow model in this example we will
not dive deep into the explanation of
the model as it is beyond the scope of
this video
so here we are using amnest dataset
which consists of images of handwritten
digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
library the inputs will look something
like this
then we create our tensorflow model to
create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session
then after training the model we can
validate the data and then predict the
accuracy this model
has predicted 92 accuracy let's see
which is pretty well for this model so
that's all for tensorflow if you need to
understand this tutorial in detail
then you can go ahead and watch our deep
learning tutorial from simply learn
as shown in the right corner interesting
right let's move on to the next library
now let's talk about a common yet a very
powerful python library called numpy
numpy is a fundamental package for
numerical computation in python it
stands for numerical python as the name
suggests
it has around 18 000 comments on github
with an active community of
700 contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package
in a way that it provides high
performance multi-dimensional objects
called
arrays and tools for working with them
also numpy addresses the slowness
problem partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then
functions and operators that operate
efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of number
it's very easy to work with large arrays
and matrices using numpy numpy fully
supports object oriented approach
for example coming back to nd array once
again it's a class possessing numerous
methods
and attributes ndra provides for larger
and repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster
and compact than traditional methods i
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that
now let's talk about the applications of
numpy numpy
along with pandas is extensively used in
data analysis
which forms the basis of data science it
helps in creating the powerful
n-dimensional array whenever we talk
about
numpy the mention of the array we cannot
do it
without the mention of the powerful
n-dimensional array
also number is extensively used in
machine learning
when we are creating machine learning
models as in where it forms the base of
other libraries like sci-by scikit-learn
etc when you start creating the machine
learning models in data science you will
realize
that all the models will have their
bases numpy or pandas
also when numpy is used with scipy and
matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of matlab now let's look at
a simple example
of an array in numpy as you can see here
there are multiple
array manipulation routines like there
are basic examples where you can copy
the values from one array to another we
can give a new shape to an
array from maybe one dimensional we can
make it as a two dimensional
array we can return a copy of the array
collapsed into one dimension
now let's look at an example where this
is a jubilee notebook
and we will just create a basic array
and
for detailed explanation you can watch
our other videos
which targets on these explanations of
each libraries so first of all whenever
we are using any library in python we
have to import it
so now this np is the alias which we
will be using
let's create a simple array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an end array type of array
also let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can
expand the shape of the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using
all those functions now let's create
another using arrange functions
if i give arrange 12 it will give me a
1d array of 12 numbers
like this now we can reshape this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how our range function and
the reshape function works
for numpy now let's discuss the next
library which is scipy
so this is another free and open source
python library extensively used in data
science
for high level computations so this
library as the name suggests stands for
scientific python
and it has around 19 000 comments on
github with an active community of 600
contributors
it is extensively used for scientific
and technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations
now let's discuss about some features of
scipy so scipy has its collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high level
commands for data manipulation
and visualization also the ndmh function
of scipy is
very useful in multi-dimensional image
processing
and it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations
linear algebra and many more so that was
about the features of sci-fi
now let's discuss its applications so
cyber is used in multi-dimensional image
operations it has functions to read
images from disk into number arrays to
write arrays to discuss
images resize images etc solving
differential equations
fourier transforms then optimization
algorithms
linear algebra etc let's look at a
simple example to learn what kind of
functions are there in sci by
here i am importing the constants
package of scipy library
so in this package it has all the
constants
so here i am just mentioning c or
h or any and this library already knows
what it has to fetch like speed of light
planck's constant etc
so this can be used in further
calculations data analysis is an
integral part of data science data
scientists spend most of the day
in data munching and then cleaning the
data also hence mention of pandas is a
must in data science life cycle
yes pandas is the most popular and
widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comments on
github and an
active community of 1200 contributors it
is heavily used for data analysis and
cleaning as it provides
fast flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed to work
with structured data
very easily and intuitively now let's
talk about some features of pandas so
pandas offers this eloquent syntax and
rich functionalities like there are
various methods in pandas like drop
n a fill na which gives you the freedom
to deal with missing data
also partners provides a powerful apply
function
which lets you create your own function
and run it across a series of data now
forget about writing those
for loops while using pandas also this
library's high level abstraction over
low level numpy which is written in pure
c
then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so panas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling and data cleaning then pandas
also finds its usage in edl jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading csv
files into its data frame format
then pandas is used in a variety of
academic and commercial domains
including statistics finance
neuroscience economics web analytics
etc then pandas is also very useful in
time series specific functionality
like date range generation moving window
linear regression date shifting etc
now let's look at a very simple example
of how to create a data frame so data
frame is a very
useful data structure in pandas and it
has very powerful functionalities
so here i'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
i'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this
before using pandas here i'm importing
the pandas library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can
import a file a csv file excel files
there are many functions
doing these things and we can also
create
our own data and put it into data frame
so here i am
taking random data and putting in a data
frame also i'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names
so pd is the alias we've given pandas
random data of 6x4 index which is taking
a range of six numbers
and column name i'm giving as abcd now
let's
go ahead and look at it so here it has
created a data frame with my column
names abcd
my list has six numbers zero to five
and a random data of six by four
so data frame is just another table with
rows and columns where you can do
various functions over it
also i can go ahead and describe
this data frame to see so it's giving me
all these
functionalities where count and mean and
standard deviation
etc okay so that was about pandas now
let's talk about
next library and the last one so
matplotlib for me is the most
fun library out of all of them why
because it has such
powerful yet beautiful visualizations
we'll see in the coming slides
plot and matplotlib suggests that it's a
plotting library for python it has
around 26 000 comments on github
and a very vibrant community of 700
contributors
and because of such graphs and plots
that it produces it's majorly used for
data visualization and also because it
provides an
object-oriented api which can be used to
embed those plots into our applications
let's talk about the features of
matplotlib the pi plot module of
matplotlib provides matlab-like
interface
so matplotlib is designed to be as
usable as matlab with an advantage of
being free
and open source also it supports dozens
of backends and output types which means
you can use it regardless of which
operating system you're using or which
output format you wish
pandas itself can be used as wrappers
around matplotlibs api so as to drive
matplotlib via cleaner and more modern
apis
also when you start using this library
you will realize that it has a very
little memory consumption and a
very good runtime behavior now let's
talk about the applications of
matplotlib it's important to discover
the unknown relationship between the
variables in your data set
so this library helps to visualize the
correlation analysis of variables
also in machine learning we can
visualize 95 percent confidence interval
of the model just to communicate how
well our model fits the data
then mat modular finds its application
and outlier detection using scatter plot
etc
and to visualize the distribution of
data to gain instant insights
now let's make a very simple plot to get
a basic idea
i've already imported the libraries here
so this function matplotlib inline will
help you
show the plots in the jupiter notebook
this is also called a magic function
i won't be able to display my plots in
the jupiter notebook if i don't use this
function
i am using this function in numpy
to fix random state for reproducibility
now i'll take
my n as 30 and will assign random values
to my variables
so this function is generating 30 random
numbers
here i'm trying to create a scatter plot
so i
want to decide the area let's
put this so this is multiplying 30 with
random numbers
to the power 2 so that we get the area
of the plot which we will see in just a
minute
so using the scatter function and the
alias of
matplotlib as plt i've created this
if i don't use this and i have very
small
circles as my scatter plot it's colorful
it's nice
so that's one very easy plot i suggest
that you explore more of matplotlib and
i'm sure you will enjoy it
let's create a histogram so i'm using my
style as gg plot and assigning some
values to these variables any random
values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
alignment to the plot
and here we get the graph so we can
create different type of visualizations
and plots
and then work upon them using matplotlib
and it's just that simple
so this was about top python libraries
for data science according to me
it still may not cover some other great
useful libraries that deserve to be
looked at
so share your favorites in the comment
section below as well as any interesting
things about the libraries that we
mentioned
that's all from my site thank you and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here